education is of the ultimate poverty
eradication tool when you know better
you tend to do better we all know this
we all know that in Africa you give a
woman two years of primary school
education in a village in Africa you
lift the entire village out of poverty
we know the power of Education in China
and the power of Education in the
developing world yet we do so little yet
we tend to have ready fire aim we wait
to the last minute we don't make that
our first investments why don't
governments do this why don't they make
this a larger priority I in my book love
leadership a new way to lead in a
fear-based world I talk about laziness
as well fear as a lazy bastard there's
two things in the world is love and
there's fear and what you don't love you
fear in fierce first cousin is laziness
and laziness his best friend is
short-termism a focus on me and not we
what do we have to get versus what we
have to give and this immediate
gratification in greed and so it is our
short term nature it is the immediacy of
politics versus the long-term nature of
public service that has got us trapped
in this vicious cycle and what I've said
is if you want to make a lot of money
you want to do really well there's
nothing best work better for you or
worse for society than repression in the
short term but over the long term you'll
hit a wall and we've hit a wall around
the world if you say that's another
recession it's a reset and so we're
going to have a start making long-term
investments in everything the
environment in our economy financial
literacy is a example of a long-term
investment and education is the ultimate
way to break the back of poverty in
America thirty percent of all students
are dropping out of high school in the
largest economy in the world fifty
percent of all urban kids are dropping
out of high school and seventy percent
of black men are dropping out of high
school it's an economic death sentence
and it is not sustainable we need to
make smart sexy again we need to make a
long term investment to reframe
education and smart sexy and cool and I
guess the last thing I'll say is
developing countries where kids are
dropping out of high school we're in
developing countries kids are just
trying to get into school but in
developed countries they're jumping out
of high school they're dropping out
because they don't think education is
relevant to their future how you make it
relevant show kids how to prosper how to
succeed and how to do well and even how
to get rich as they want to legally
that's financial literacy free
enterprise and capitalism ownership
opportunity and entrepreneurship even if
you're dealing with a drug dealer he's
not dumb he understands import export
supply demand wholesale retail customer
service security now talking about a
dumb kid come out a misdirected kid so
let's give them a role model that's
given some relevant education let's give
them the opportunity to apply those
skills and to improve their lives and we
will see education be the ultimate
long-term investment in our society and
that's doing well in doing good doing
well by doing good you want to help go
to 5m k dot or 5 million kids out of
work help Quincy Jones Andrew Young and
myself to make smart sexy again thank
you very much